[Applaus]
[Musik]
liberia ist eines jener afrikanischen
länder in denen es praktisch keine
gesetze gibt außer einem murphys gesetz
und das besagt wenn in liberia etwas
schiefgehen kann wird es auf jeden fall
schief gehen ich wette dass viele von
euch gar keine ahnung haben was liberia
überhaupt ist oder wo es liegt und weiß
doch dass ich das vielleicht daran dass
der eine andere von euch in der
steuerhinterziehung der
steueroptimierung branche arbeitet ja so
ist es
liberia ist eines der grössten
steuerparadiese dieser welt obwohl seine
bürger ganz und gar nicht einen so
ausgefallenen lebensstil pflegen wie die
einwohner monacos gut wie funktioniert
nun dieses steuerparadies also wenn du
eine in liberia registrierte firma hast
aber die aktivitäten dieser firma
außerhalb des landes stattfinden zahlt
diese firma keine steuern so einfach ist
das
[Musik]
und falls du jetzt nicht unbedingt viel
bock drauf hast dafür in ein
geheimnisvolles und abgelegenes
afrikanisches land zu fliegen macht ihr
gar keine sorgen er sagte dass man sich
in liberia befinden muss um dort eine
firma zu gründen liberianische
handelsregister gibt es nämlich in
wesentlich besseren lagen wie zb zürich
london oder tokio
in all diesen städten gibt es büros in
denen sie ihre liberianische firma
registrieren lassen können und welche
arten von unternehmen sind in liberia
registriert sind es banken technologie
unternehmen nicht ganz die große
spezialität liberias sind schiffe
das mag viele von euch überraschen außer
er lebt in einer hafenstadt wenn ihr
einen seehafen der nähe habt konntet ihr
sicher schon viele schiffe mit dieser
flagge oder mit dem wort monrovia auf
den rumpf
ob ihr es glaubt oder nicht liberia ist
das zweitgrößte schiffsregister der
weltnummer 1 auf der liste ist panama
auch sehr ähnlichen gründen günstige
besteuerung gut ich weiß was du jetzt
denkst wenn liberia für ausländische
unternehmen so attraktiv ist und sie so
viele schiffe haben muss es sich doch um
ein sehr wohlhabendes land handeln ohne
dass singapur afrikas eine reiche oase
inmitten eines armen content es nicht
war
nun das gegenteil ist das sollte liberia
ist eines der fünf ärmsten länder der
welt und wir sprechen hier nicht einfach
nur von unterentwickelt oder von einer
rezession gebeutelt liberias
bruttoinlandsprodukt pro kopf beträgt
weniger als 1000 dollar pro jahr
das bedeutet dass uganda doppelt zu
erreichen ist oder ab so armee nachdem
wie man es sieht die heutige frage
lautet also wie kann eine schifffahrt
macht und ein steuerparadies will iberia
so arm sein
heute werden wir diese frage beantworten
aber bevor wir dies tun wollen wir wie
immer einen blick zurück in die
geschichte werfen
[Musik]
die afro amerikanische nation sklaverei
gehörst du den schändlichsten teilen der
geschichte der usa wie ihr wisst war bis
zum amerikanischen bürgerkrieg die
sklaverei in den südstaaten legal viele
grossgrundbesitzer ließen afrikanische
sklaven auf ihren feldern schuf
[Musik]
und ich weiß was du wahrscheinlich
denkst was haben die sklaven in den usa
mit liberia zu tun und was hat all das
mit steueroasen schiffen und
afrikanischen länder zu tun nur die
wahrheit ist dass es ohne die
sklavenhaltung in usa ein land namens
liberia gar nicht geben würde
gehen wir also zurück in den
amerikanischen stil
[Musik]
wie ihr vielleicht schon wisst bei den
usa am anfang des neunzehnten
jahrhundert die sklavenhaltung in den
landwirtschaftlich geprägten südstaaten
gang und gäbe wären sie in den bereits
industrialisierten nordstaaten verboten
war
als folge davon flohen viele sklaven aus
orten im süden die mississippi alabama
in örtliche staaten wie elena order new
york wo die sklaverei ja verboten war
diese sklaven flucht war für den süden
ein stetes ärgernis wieso nun nicht nur
weil sie es nicht mochten das ihren er
arbeitskapital abhaut sondern auch weil
viele der ehemaligen sklaven die im
norden zuflucht fanden in die südstaaten
zurückkehren und ihre leidensgenossen
befreien wollen
viele politiker des südens übten daher
druck auf die politik des nordens aus
damit sie keine afrikanischen
flüchtlinge mehr aufnehmen natürlich
waren die politiker in den nordstaaten
nicht bereit dies zu tun und so
schmerzhaft ist auch ist auf diese weise
über menschenleben und menschliche
schicksale zu sprechen
dies alles ist tatsächlich passiert
damals sah man diese grausamen dinge als
teil einer völlig legitimen debatten und
so einigten sich die beiden seiten auf
einen kaltherzigen kompromiss die
ehemaligen sklaven sollten in ein
anderes land geschickt werden so begann
die american cancer society im jahr 1822
schiffe in das heutige liberia zu
schicken
dieser ort wurde nicht zufällig
ausgewählt die usa hatten nämlich dieses
land wurden lokal ish damit angehörigen
gekauft und dabei wirklich keinerlei
kosten gescheut sie bis halten dafür
ganze 300 dollar
und deshalb heißt die liberianischen
hauptstadt monrovia zu ehren von james
monroe dem damaligen amerikanischen
präsidenten monroe selbst war ein sklave
halter aus dem süden also denke nicht
einmal eine minute daran dass er all
dies aus warmherzigkeit us oder etwa um
die sklaverei zu beenden
übrigens um fair zu sein sollten wir
erwähnen dass die amerikaner nicht die
einzigen mit einem solchen
umsiedlungsprogramm für ehemalige
sklaven waren liberia gibt es ein
weiteres land namens zora leone mit
einer sehr ähnlichen geschichte in
diesem fall war es das britische empire
dass seine ehemaligen sklaven dorthin
verfrachtet
also die traurige geschichte liberias
ist dass es als amerikanischer kolonie
begann um für diejenigen armen menschen
einen zufluchtsort zu bieten
die der süden versklaven und der norden
nicht aufnehmen wollte eigentlich war es
ja auch ziemlich ironisch dass die usa
also ein land das sich selbst als
ehemalige kolonie die unabhängigkeit
erkämpft hatte jetzt selbst als
kolonialmacht auftrat daher wurde im
jahr 1847 liberia schließlich in die
unabhängigkeit entlassen und somit ein
souveränes land die beziehungen zu den
usa blieben aber extrem eng und damit
wären wir auch schon bei der auflösung
unserer frage mit den vielen schiffs
registrierungen in liberia sehen wir uns
das mal aus der nähe an
[Applaus]
billigfleisch die ehemalige sklaven die
nun als freie männer bürger liebe es
waren brachten die schlimmste
südamerikas mit in ihre neue heimat die
sklaverei ja ich weiß das klingt
furchtbar und zynisch aber es ist wahr
die ehemaligen amerikanischen sklaven
wurden zu einer elite die die bereits in
den beeren lebenden lokalen
stammesangehörigen skrupellos was
klappte dies elite ist bekannt als die
amerikaner oder auch kreolen und
regierte das land bis ins jahr 1980 das
ist mehr als ein jahrhundert wie ich
bereits erwähnt habe unterhielt diese
elite wirklich enge beziehungen zu den
vereinigten staaten und das erklärt die
geschehnisse nach dem zweiten weltkrieg
[Applaus]
damals begannen der kalte krieg und
eiserne vorhang teilte die welt in zwei
hälften den kommunistischen osten und
den kapitalistischen westen der kalte
krieg war im vollen gange und das
bedeutete dass viele us geschäftsleute
nicht mehr mit der sowjetunion und ihren
verbündeten handel treiben durften das
gleiche spielte sich in vielen anderen
westlichen ländern ab wie sie sich
vorstellen können hatte dies einen
enormen einfluss auf die internationale
schifffahrt industrie
[Musik]
und da sagten die us reedereien zum
weißen haus erhalte willst du uns etwas
vorschreiben dass wir mit unseren
schiffen nicht die sowjetischen häfen an
trocken dürfen
sollen wir etwa aufhören mit der hälfte
der welt handelt so treiben nur wegen
ihrer politischen sandkasten hänseleien
aber klar doch gewiss wir werden
natürlich alle regeln befolgen weil wir
die politik ja so sehr mehr lieben als
den schnöden mammon geld verdienen ist
doch gar nicht so wichtig für uns nicht
wahr
und so entstand das konzept der
billigflieger immer wenn eine reederei
aus den usa oder eine mit den usa
verbündeten land ihrer schiffe in einen
hafen schicken wollte wohin schiffe aus
den usa oder mit ihnen verbündeten
länder nicht fahren durften musste sie
sich etwas einfallen lassen wie wär's
zum beispiel diese schiffe einfach auf
ein anderes land umzumelden das nicht
diesen restriktionen unterlag tja und
welches land war bereit dazu mitten im
kalten krieg gegen eine handvoll dollar
eine neutrale haltung einzunehmen ja du
hast es traten unser schönes liberia für
die liberianische regierung bedeutete
dies einfach nur jede menge knete fürs
nichtstun money for nothing chips für
vieh und deshalb wollten sie für die us
reedereien den roten teppich aus
tatsächlich sagten sie hey leute wollt
ihr euch wirklich bis in unser
verschwitztes büro in monrovia schleppen
eure schiffe zu registrieren warum
schaut ihr stattdessen nicht lieber in
unserer brandneuen klimatisierten
filiale im us staat virginia vorbei das
ist bequemer für euch weil ihr nicht
reisen müsst und bequemer für uns was er
hier in monrovia keinen finger rühren
müssen und deshalb ist der hauptsitz des
liberianischen schiffsregister das nicht
in monrovia sondern in virginia und so
wurde liberia irgendwann schließlich zur
größten schifffahrtsnationen der welt
größer als die vereinigten staaten
größer als das vereinigte königreich und
größer als jedes andere land oder empire
in der geschichte zuvor auch heute noch
fahren elf prozent aller schiffe in
internationalen gewässern unter
liberianischer flagge
das sind es 3500 schiffe mit über 124
millionen bruttoregistertonnen war eine
einwohnerzahl iberia von weniger als
fünf millionen
das klingt schon ein wenig verrückt aber
auf der welt gibt ist nunmal so einige
folgten dinge und dies ist ein guter
moment euch daran zu erkennen dass er
jede woche brandneue geschichten über
verrücktheiten auf der ganzen welt
veröffentlichen also abonniert uns bitte
damit ihr keine folge verpasst aber
kommen wir zurück zu unserer geschichte
[Musik]
denn jetzt fragt ihr euch vielleicht
eines der kalte krieg ist auch schon
seit 30 jahren vorbei warum stehen also
immer noch so viele reedereien schlange
und ihre schiffe gerade in liberia zu
registrieren nun zunächst einmal wieder
liberia als steueroase diskussion
darüber wem jedes einzelne schiff gehört
zweites gibt es viele wirtschaftliche
vorteile werdet euch an das bild das wir
euch vorhin gezeigt haben es war ein
riesiges containerschiff mit dem namen
monrovia auf dem rumpf allein durch die
registrierung in liberia stadt etwa in
den vereinigten staaten hat der
eigentümer schon mal rund 17.000 dollar
gespart aber das ist nur die spitze des
eisbergs die iberia hat zum beispiel ein
spezielles handelsabkommen hier das
einem viel geld für celle und steuern
sparen kann und was bekommt liberia im
gegenzug für all das nun ein paar dollar
im jahr
die sie sonst nicht bekommen würden
wieviel genau nun wir sprechen hier von
etwa 25 millionen dollar pro jahr im
globalen maßstab ist das nicht viel geld
aber da es sich um ein so kleines und
armes land endet macht das ganze sechs
prozent der staatseinnahmen liberias aus
und denkt dran egal wie groß oder klein
dieser betrag ist liberia bekommt das
geld praktisch ohne den finger krümmen
zu müssen
[Musik]
iberia als zweitgrößtes schiffsregister
der welt bestätigt okay okay ich weiß
was du es sagen willst da haben wir es
mal wieder visual politik setzt sich für
steueroasen ein und unterstützt gucken
lose geschäftsleute und an dieser stelle
wird uns markt davon erzählen wie
liberia dabei ist das afrikanische
singapur zu werden ein reiches und
wohlhabendes land dank einer freundlich
politik stimmt es nein auch wenn einige
von euch jetzt enttäuscht sein lernen
aber die antwort ist nein tatsächlich
ist das genaue gegenteil der fall schaut
euch mal folgendes an
[Musik]
vom bürgerkrieg zum goldenen ball wie
ich euch bereits erzielter ab regierten
die amerikanischen liga das land bis sie
im jahre 1980 durch einen staatsstreich
ihre macht verloren endlich hatte
liberia einen einheimischen
liberianischen herrscher
dies hätte eine großartige nachricht das
land sein können aber in wirklichkeit
wurde damit die saat für zwei blutige
bürgerkriege gelegt in denen die
warlords um die kontrolle über dieses
land rein
es handelt sich um einen der dunkelsten
traurigsten und unmenschlichen
abschnitte der jüngsten geschichte mit
kindersoldaten illegalem waffenhandel
und brutale folterungen hast du mal den
film lord of vorgesehen das ist ein
toller film mit nicolas cage in der
hauptrolle
mittels cage ist eine der am meisten
unterschätzten schauspieler hollywoods
da in seinem privatleben nicht besonders
gut mit geld umgehen kann und in seine
überbordende schulden regelmäßig dazu
nötigen rollen in spielfilmen anzunehmen
aber dieser film ist keiner dieser
schutzstreifen hier stellt cage seine
großartigen schauspielerischen
fähigkeiten unter beweis und das ist
ganz und gar nicht sarkastisch gemeint
wir können euch den film wirklich nur
empfehlen es geht darin um die zeit nach
dem fall der udssr als viel
waffenhändler altes politische waffen zu
sehr niedrigen preisen auf kaufen und an
afrikanische diktatoren verhökerten
derartige geschäfte waren in vielen
ländern der welt statt und wie das hirn
zeigt war liberia eines der wichtigsten
davon aber auch hier war die realität
noch unvorstellbar schlimmer und
grausamer als das was man in filmen
sehen
[Musik]
innerhalb von 17 jahren starben mehr als
eine viertelmillion liberianer dies
entsprach 8 prozent der bevölkerung
hinzu kamen viele vertriebene und die
flächendeckende wirtschaftlicher
verwüstungen des ganzen landes doch was
direkt nach diesem chaos geschah war
nichts weniger als ein wunder
[Musik]
nach dem zweiten bürgerkrieg in der
diktator charles taylor ins exil und das
land ging in eine demokratie wird seit
2005 finden regelmäßig freie
demokratische wahlen statt nun zumindest
nach den dort liegenden regionalen
maßstäben einigermaßen demokratisch
wählen dürfen zum beispiel nur menschen
afrikanischer abstammung ich zitiere
artikel 27 der liberianischen verfassung
zum zwecke der bewahrung und förderung
der positiven leitkultur wert ordnung
und ist ragt als liberias dürfen nur
personen die schwarze oder von schwarzer
abstammung sind durch geburt oder
einbürgerung die staatsangehörigkeit
liberias erhalten war
stellt euch mal vor jemand würde fordern
so eine rassistische denke in der
amerikanischen oder in der deutschen
verfassung zu verankern aber immerhin
ist die lage liberias besser als zu
zeiten des allgegenwärtigen massenmords
und massen elends zum beispiel gibt es
in liberia mittlerweile ein
bildungssystem das auf preiswerte
private schulen setzt das
verbesserungspotenzial ist jedoch noch
gewaltig im jahre 2006 wurde ellen
johnson sirleaf die erste weibliche
regierungschefin afrikas und dirigierte
liberia zwölf jahre lang ihre verwaltung
hatte einige positive aber auch viele
negative aspekte
[Musik]
so vielen jahren des krieges hat sich
die stabilität geschaffen die das land
dringend benötigte und mit viel
internationaler hilfe konnte sie mit dem
wiederaufbau des landes beginnen ihre
bemühungen führten dazu dass die 2011
sogar den friedensnobelpreis erhielt
aber sie hatte auch eine dunkle seite
und diese war mal korruption nachdem sie
sich jahrelang ihre rolle als sauber
frauen kämpferin gegen die korruption
gegeben hatte fand man ihren namen in
den paradise papers als real
eigentümerin einer geldwäsche firma auf
den bermudas
sie verschaffte ihren söhnen auch
positionen in staatlichen unternehmen
aber trotz all dem muss man sagen dass
sich die lage im land in riesenschritten
verändert wenn nur noch klebt omanische
politiker das hauptproblem sind und
nicht wahllos und kindersoldaten
es ist nun mal immer das gleiche problem
wenn ein land von internationaler
entwicklungshilfe abhängig ist das
meiste geld fließt letzten endes
manchmal mehr manchmal weniger umwege in
die taschen einiger weniger
anstatt der mehrheit zu helfen denn
seien wir mal ehrlich was ist
mittlerweile der wichtigste
wirtschaftszweig in liberia wo mitmacht
liberia mehr umsatz mit schiffen und
steueroptimierung zusammengenommen nun
das haupt exportgut dieses landes ist
nicht kakao oder gummi sondern mitleid
erregende betroffenheit und ich kann
euch sagen die mitleids branche liberias
ist dabei verdammt erfolgreich denn sie
schafft es dass trotz der tollen von
geld die internationale
hilfsorganisation dort jahr für jahr
abladen das land noch wie vor die
spitzenplätze aller armut ranglisten
hält natürlich hat der durchschnitts
liberianer nichts davon
dafür aber umso mehr die politiker denen
geht so richtig gut und falls ihr
dachtet die korruption in liberia hätte
damit bereits ihren höhepunkt erreicht
schaut euch lieber mal das jahr
[Musik]
george bähr von fußballspieler zum
präsidenten liberias falls ihr älter als
30 jahre sein
meldet euch vielleicht an george w er
war fußball stürmer bei paris-nizza ac
mailand und chelsea er gewann 1995 den
goldenen ball und ist im grunde eine
fußball-legende also will er natürlich
seine karriere in der politik fortsetzen
und du fragst dich vielleicht was macht
er da was sind seine prioritäten als
präsident eines zu armen landes könnte
man meinen dass er sich darauf
konzentriert investoren anzuziehen know
how zu schaffen und einheimische
unternehmen aufzubauen
etwas in dieser richtung nicht war okay
dann seht euch mal an was er wirklich
treibt die johanna toren 52 nigeria
tja manche männer lösen ihre midlife
crisis durch den kauf einer harley
davidson aber als liberianische
präsident gibt man ein vermögen aus um
ein fußballspiel mit der
nationalmannschaft zu organisieren damit
man wieder mitspielen kann und sich ein
seine glorreichen zeiten erinnert aber
du denkst jetzt wahrscheinlich über mart
das war doch nur ein tag das kann nicht
alles sein was als präsident leistet ich
bin mir sicher er tut außerdem noch
andere dinge und du hast ja recht jw
setzt stark auf die infrastruktur hört
sich ziemlich vernünftig an geld das
problem ist dass es sich dabei
hauptsächlich um die straßen rund um
sein eigenes privathaus handelt darüber
hinaus hat er den wiederaufbau in genau
jenem vor ort in dem er aufgewachsen ist
zu seiner priorität erklärt er nutzt
seine politische macht nicht nur um
seine midlife crisis zu lösen sondern
auch um seine kindheitstraumata zu
heilen aber auch im ausland findet wer
viel raum für seine korrupten
machenschaften
[Musik]
liberias dächer projekt in gibraltar
unter verdacht laut zahlungsanweisungen
wurden über eine million us dollar
ausgegeben
ob dieser meldung zufolge schätzen
fachleute die kosten für dieses projekt
auch etwa die hälfte der real
ausgezahlten gelder und dies ist nur ein
weiterer skandal unter vielen vielen
anderen verbrachte steuergelder sind das
eine problem aber das größere problem
ist dass alle via wähler jetzt verdammt
enttäuscht sind und auch empört er war
erhält einer von ihnen einer der es
geschafft hatte und ihnen hoffnung gab
man muss sich vor augen halten dass
gerade george wir eine der wenigen
liberianischen erfolgsgeschichten war
ein vorbild für alle und dieser
sündenfall zeigt ein großes risiko für
die liberianische gesellschaft auf die
wirtschaft läuft schlecht die preise
steigen und die arbeitslosigkeit ist
sowieso schon hoch in monrovia kommt es
immer häufiger zu protesten
und wenn ihr euch gesagt haben ist dies
das lang in dem murphys gesetz reagiert
alles was schiefgehen kann geht auch
schief und schief gehen bedeutet in
diesem fall auch die gefahr eines
weiteren bürgerkriegs aber jetzt seid
ihr an der reihe uns eure meinung zu
sagen
glaubt ihr dass liberia sein status als
steuerparadies irgendwie nutzen könnte
um aus der armut herauszukommen oder
befindet es sich erneut auf dem weg in
einen weiteren bürgerkrieg wie immer
freuen wir uns auf eure hessischen und
emotional aufgeladenen kommentare und
auch auf alle anderen
außerdem solltet ihr wissen dass wir
jede woche neue frisch und informative
videos für euch drehen und
veröffentlicht wenn ihr also keines
dieser aktuellen atx verpassen wollt
abonniert bitte bis wollen politik und
drückt danach auf das glöckchen wenn
euch dieses video gefallen hat dann geht
uns einen daumen hoch bis zum nächsten
mal
[Musik]
[Applaus]